ante miles de seguidores el presidente
de brasil el ultraderechista jair
bolsonaro habló sobre el supuesto
enemigo de brasil en una clara alusión a
las elecciones de este 2022 ya la
posible candidatura del ibis inácio lula
da silva
nuestro enemigo no es externo es interno
no es una lucha de la izquierda contra
la derecha
es una lucha del bien contra el mal
rumbo
[Aplausos]
y ganaremos esta batalla
bolsonaro convocó el evento con el
partido liberal al que se afilió en
noviembre para lanzar su candidatura
para los comicios de octubre según el
cronograma electoral la campaña para las
elecciones de octubre no puede comenzar
hasta el 16 de agosto pero si se
permiten eventos que son prácticamente
idénticos en este el mandatario
aprovechó para criticar el último sondeo
de datafolha que demuestra que lula da
silva acumula una intención de voto del
43 por ciento muy por delante de
bolsonaro al que se le adjudica un 26%
huapi una encuesta mentirosa pública a
mil veces no convertirá a nadie en
presidente de la república
un día ante su probable contrincante
para las elecciones lula dasilva
celebraba el centenario del partido
comunista que ya ha expresado su apoyo
al izquierdista si decide competir por
la presidencia
en 2022 se levantarán a las 7 de la
mañana
y
se darán un baño se peinarán y sacarán a
bolsonaro de la presidencia de este país
de cara a los comicios de octubre brasil
enfrenta un aumento de la inflación ya
instalada y el precio del combustible
debido a la guerra en ucrania en un país
en el que más de 12 millones de personas
están desempleadas